The answer is we get a smooth path.
To see why that's the case, let me just simulate the optimization.
Suppose we're given a solution to the planning problem like this,
and you run the optimization algorithm. Consider a place like this.
By shifting this point into that direction,
and perhaps shifting the other points in other directions,
we can decrease the second error term,
both for this pair of points, and this pair of points.
However, we do this at the expense of the first error term,
since we're now shifting the point away from the original x.
Depending on the weight of these error terms, we might arrive with like the following.
This new path suffers an error of the first type that we moved the points away
from the original points, but it drastically reduces the inter-point distance
as in this error term over here.
If you insist that the original points are not changed,
then just exclude those from the optimization.
In fact, in our exercise, we will not consider those points
Y0 will always been the same as x0, and yn-1 will always be the same as xn-1,
assuming we have n points starting in x0.
The optimization is only applied to the intermediary points.